m
aussi à l'organisation de telles tout ce
qui est en train de se passer alors donc
comme ça nous allons aller dans le vif
du sujet
lorsque j'étais au lycée j'ai découvert
la programmation des amis et moi nous
nous amusions à créer de petits
logiciels pour calculatrice ses
logiciels étaient effectivement petit
dès le départ il affichait du texte
choses basiques mais après ils sont
devenus de plus en plus complexes donc
nous ce que nous avons fait c'est que
par exemple des programmes pour
faciliter des équations pour rendre de
mathématiques plus plus rapide nous
avons fait les programmes pour faire de
l'animation graphique inspiré par les
jeux vidéo et même un certain moment
nous avons touché à l'intelligence
artificielle et tout ce qui était
probabilité en fait de mouvement
et ceci dit notre nos efforts les plus
mémorables qui sont restés des années
après des années durant sont les
adaptations sur calculatrice de jeux
vidéo phare de l'époque tels que zelda
et pokémon
et après le bac mes amis et moi ça a été
la dispersion moi j'ai atterri en
angleterre
à l'université de westminster continuer
dans la filière génie logiciel et juste
après ça je suis tombé amoureux
du cinéma de la photographie
et comment est-ce que ça s'est passé je
marchais dans une rue tout en cordes
gros lalonde qui est célèbre pour ses
magasins d'électroménager lorsque j'ai
vu dans une vitrine une bande annonce
celle de la matrice de la première
bande-annonce m'avait fait un grand
effet quand j'étais encore au lycée et
je pense que ce n'est pas un hasard que
j'ai mis ce deuxième grand effet lorsque
le deuxième opus de la saga a été sortie
est là lorsque j'ai vu cette bande
annonce je me suis dit je pense que je
peux faire ce genre de choses je pense
que j'ai l'imagination pour je pense que
j'ai le coeur pur je vais y aller et
cette bande-annonce a révélé et
cristallisé en une fraction de seconde
cette envie de faire de grands films
étant étudiant en informatique j'avais
déjà compris et connaissant le passionné
que je suis j'ai préféré ne pas
souhaiter de plain pied dans le cinéma
et je me suis octroyer on va dire une
passion pour le pour la photographie
étant donné qu'elle à l'unité de l'image
animée
et là j'ai fais un voeu
j'avais compris en voyant le box office
les grands films des grands réalisateurs
j'avais compris que une oeuvre
artistique touché de grandes masses et
alors là mon voeu était le suivant paul
il faut que ce que tu produisent
contribuer à la construction positive de
l'humanité et là mon chemin il a
vraiment commencé alors de photos en
photo je suis allée d'expérimentation
une expérimentation jusqu'à définir un
style un ensemble de principes qui
allait sous tendre ma vision et ma
direction artistique et cette direction
artistique je l'appelais photo making
dans l'étymologie véhicule ses
influences
photographie et firmin king qui veut
bien entendu jeudi un cinéma en anglais
avec un accent sur le processus de la
réalisation de ceux ci
lorsqu'à prochain là la période faut
choisir des projets de fin de cycle à
l'université de westminster mon prof
docteur nas qui me prenaient en
programmation de réseaux me dit paul
j'aimerais bien que tu me mets de ce
quelque chose je trouvais ça très
intéressant je ne m'attendais vraiment
pas à ce que un prof viennent me
solliciter pour quoi que ce soit alors
il me dit je suis en train de travailler
sur un sujet particulier et j'aimerais
que tu m'aies recherche et là il ne
sortit une thématique un sujet que
j'avais jamais dont j'avais jamais
entendu parler et là il me dit paul
j'aimerais que tu traites parce que tu
as cette sensibilité là et c'est un mot
pôle informatique je voudrais que tu te
fais ce sujet là pour moi l'art
collaboratif massif sur l'internet pour
moi c'était une joie
jamais senti j'avais art et technologie
mes deux passions ensemble sur un même
projet
et
là j'ai lui et moi avons commencé bien
entendu assez évident que j'acceptais
d'office j'ai lui et moi on a commencé
donc à discuter à discuter rendez-vous
dans son bureau et a au moment où nous
allions entamé de profonde discussion
sur la thématique
il y avait plus de nouvelles je
n'arrivais plus à contacter de monsieur
menacée je ne comprenais pas pourquoi
j'ai envoyé un mail 2003 mais pas de
réponse qu'est ce que j'ai fait je les
vois la doyenne de la faculté madame
brennan je lui ai dit madame brennan je
n'arrive plus à contacter dr ce que je
ne comprends pas pourquoi elle me dit
vas-y je te je te ferai je te ferai
signe plus tard je reviendrai vers toi
d'accord et un jour on me en attire mon
attention
l'admistration attire mon attention et
me dit que dr nassr ne reviendra plus je
dis non mais je ne comprends pas bien
qu'est ce qui se passe et c'est là qu'on
m'annonce que docteur nas était en train
de était dans sept derniers jours en
réalité est que tout ce temps que je
n'arrivais pas à le joindre en fait il
avait il tentant de se soigner parce
qu'il avait un cancer il avait une
tumeur au cerveau et la réalité après
c'est qu'ils n'avaient pas survécu
quand j'ai appris ça
j'étais j'avais jamais pas de mots
je disais non mais c'est pas possible
mais c'était la réalité est là
pour moi beaucoup de choses ont changé
et il ya eu un effet de dominos et une
grande partie de moments de s'est
effondré
et moi qui étais si passionné par
l'informatique qui connaît tout le temps
qu'ils étaient en train de faire des
recherches
g j'ai presque arrêté de coder et même
j'ai arrêté de coder des mois sont
passés je pense en six à douze mois à
peu près ea je suis revenu à abidjan je
suis revenu à abidjan
après après avoir obtenu mon diplôme
j'ai
je me suis reposé parce que j'étais
fatigué et après j'ai ressenti l'énergie
et j'ai repris j'ai commencé j'ai pas
repris l'informatique j'ai continué dans
la branche photo making et j'ai
développé ce que j'imaginais ce que
j'avais commencé à imaginer à londres et
c'est le résultat de cette première
version de photos making que je vais
commencer par vous montrer donc
ici nous avons à dallas à dallas qui est
une histoire que j'ai écrites dans le
métro je pensais erykah badu je pensais
que j'allais pouvoir la caste et pour ça
ça n'est jamais arrivé mais bon j'ai
fait la photo quand même parce que je me
suis dit faut pas trop attendre
ensuite encore une fois à dallas
à sanaa diallo
un des personnages féeriques ancêtres
d'une plus grande collection à venir
un site à diallo sa cousine
adorateur me
réalisée avec mon ami lasnier muriel
une miss côte d'ivoire
sharon fire qui à voir avec la diversité
je vous dirai pourquoi
vous voyez ces trois personnes elles
sont en train d'éteindre un feu ce
qu'elles ont dans les mains ce sont des
petits sachets des petits sachets d'eau
qu'on retrouve en côte d'ivoire un peu
partout mais il ya une déficience
l'outil les moyens n'ont rien à voir ne
sont pas proportionnels n'a rien à voir
avec le la problématique à éteindre avec
le feu est donc là ceci était un tribut
un tribute c'était une c'était une façon
pour moi de de matérialiser ce que je
pensais non seulement de la jeunesse
même aussi des plus âgés mais c'était
pour moi une façon de me souvenir et de
montrer à quel point
on pouvait être sous on pouvait se
trouver dans des situations difficiles
et avoir des moyens qui n'était pas
appropriée cependant il faut pas arrêter
là parce que c'est dans ce genre de
moments en fait dans ce genre de la
diversité quand se définit ce genre de
moments
qu'on construit son caractère parce
qu'il ne faut pas abandonner et c'est là
en fait qu'on démonte vraiment notre
persévérance
ceci a été fait pour foukhari dit un ami
lada fakhri design est une une ligne
d'une fashion et nous avons travaillé
ensemble sur 100 photos chute
ici global go sport nous sommes des gens
nous sommes dans des environnements qui
sont très imbibés de religion la culture
est très très spirituelle et la gorgue
au spo a été basée sur le sermon sur la
montagne donc le personnage que vous
voyez est une acculturation de jésus
alors après photo making version une
il ya eu de belles conséquence
il ya eu une invitation google pour
parler de corbas que j'avais utilisé des
réseaux sociaux pour faire la promotion
il ya eu la parution sur cnn parce que
j'avais été votée artistes africains
favori par le public il ya eu aussi une
parution dans forbes en tout cas des
choses se sont bien passées une surprise
aussi a été gagnée ouest une
présentation son blog
mais ça c'était cool et à mais nous
n'allons pas nous n'allons pas nous
arrêter là qu'est ce que nous avons fait
on a continué on est parti pour photo
making version 2
encore plus profonde
et c'est ce que je vais vous montrer la
la photo mais king ou version 2 est
intitulé l'appel de lilian l'appel de
lilian étant un le titre d'une de cette
histoire qui constituent cette
collection d'histoires et de photos
l'appel de lilian alors là je commence
je vous fait dans l'esprit même de la
bande annonce je vous fais un petit tour
de la collection 2 alors là nous avons
donc délia personnage principal la jeune
dame couché dans délia était une fille
qui était très obsédé on va dire par la
réparation de la planète et il en a fait
le plein de buts dans la vie
il de nombreuses batailles ont été ont
été de nombreuses batailles
intellectuels ont été menées et au final
ils y sont arrivés
et là vous la voyez dans toute sa
splendeur
l'appel de lilian l'appel de l'ignorent
je vous montre lilian directement c'est
le personnage devrait que vous voyez sur
votre droite les liant est un
compositeur et il a réussi à mettre en
place une symphonie qui parle sommes
seulement au coeur d'une personne et
avec celle là il attirer les gens vers
lui afin de leur montrer quelque chose
de trèbes de très beaux quelque chose
qui est connu dans ce monde là comme
play et qu'est ce que payent les pelles
a été définie comme étant ce qu'il ya de
plus beau au monde paye les cinq ans à
toutes choses en grand nombre
la barbe d'alphabet le titre de cette
série là alphabet le personnage
principal viennent vous l'aurez reconnu
avec sa barbe
alphabet était un faux paresseux qui
s'est trouvé confronté à un système de
castes gouverné par la nature elle-même
et
il s'est alors
forcé il alors il sait dépasser afin de
grandir se construit et pour pouvoir
être pour pouvoir mériter la femme qu'il
aimait
ici nous avons mamie momie une princesse
d'un peuple du désert enceinte accusée
d'adultère elle décide de partir en exil
pour pouvoir maintenir le soupçon de
pettitte qui régnait encore dans son
pays et là ça s'appelle de briques dawn
of the watchers a été fait exprès c'est
la panne dure trop le goût trop étant
les petites charrettes qu'on trouve en
général en côte d'ivoire
ici nous avons marmite mousseau une
jeune dame passionnée de cuisine qui
décide de qui décide de prendre sur elle
la charge afin de retrouver et de
ramener l'abondance qui à qui mme attias
échapper son pays
et elle trouve son chemin des
personnages qui ont des idées quelque
peu chaude
ici nous avons mr tout mignon mr tout
mignon était obsédé il était il aspirait
à voir la belle croissance des enfants
il était important pour lui que les
enfants de sa génération grandissent
dans les meilleures conditions de façon
optimum et c'est comme ça qu'il
rencontrera le personnage que vous voyez
à côté et papillon qui est un personnage
collectif
un personnage collectif danse dans cette
saga est un personnage qui représente un
autre groupe de personnes et ce qui
arrive à un tel personnage arrive aux
groupes enlevant en particulier et ce
qui arrive aux groupes en particulier
arrive aussi à l'unité que papillon
était
ici nous avons jours aux
1 à l'ifa par an un chanceux évident
celui là il aspirait à réaliser les
rêves brisés des autres parce qu'il
avait réalisé la léthargie dans laquelle
son pays est en train de s'enliser
cette histoire à petit repris 9 noeuds
ok nous y sommes alors donc après photo
mais king v2 des choses aussi belle que
ce qui s'était passé après photo making
version une sont aussi arrivés mais je
me souviens d'une chose dont j'ai envie
de vous parler
il eut
une jeune dame
de france
on l'appellera marianne elle est arrivée
en côte d'ivoire vers la fin de mon
exposition de l'appel de lilian la
galerie cécile fakhoury elle est arrivée
avec une de ses amies marianne comme il
était de coutume reçu une visite guidée
de ma part bien entendu avec son ami et
pendant toute la visite guidée marianne
ne disait rien elle observait a
simplement son silence je vous le dis
étaient bruyants et jusqu'à la fin
mariën midi aucun mot
au moment de partir elle dit
principalement merci et au revoir c'est
tout
c'était curieux mais c'était intéressant
quelques jours plus tard je reçois un
email de marianne et marianne2 10
après avoir annoncé
sa bonne arrivée son bon retour en
france elle me dit paul
merci d'avoir partagé ton univers avec
nous
voici un moment
que je porte des questions auxquelles je
n'avais pas de réponse qui était très
importante pour moi
et en
recevant la visite guidée en écoutant
les histoires et en voyant les photos
j'ai obtenu mes réponses
et ce jour là
je m'en souviens encore parce qu'il
était très unique ce que j'ai ressenti
en moi je ne saurais le décrire et à je
n'oublierai jamais non seulement à cause
de la chaleur qui se dégageait de son
message mais aussi de ce que ça
représentait et j'ai parlé de quelque
chose qu'est ce que cela représente et
son message était la preuve écrite que
mon voeu d'antan de contribuer de façon
constructive à la halle à l'avancé de
l'humanité
c'était enfin réalisé et donc là ma joie
était
je sentais en fait en marianne
l'accomplissement d'une oeuvre l'at-elle
de lilian
et à ce moment là
des nombreuses choses ont commencé à me
revenir c'était la même période le code
a commencé à revenir le docteur nas a
commencé à me revenir le projet d'art
collaboratif massive sur internet a
commencé à me revenir j'ai je suis allée
de bouquins en bouquins jour et nuit je
re plonger dans un profond ressenti ma
passion d'antan
et à
la suite belle permettez moi de faire un
récapitulatif
en photo mais king version une
une vision a été formulée en photo mais
qu'une version 2
on a commencé à bâtir selon cette vision
là et on a contribué à la vie
d'officiellement une personne
mais ce qui est magnifique avec cette
contribution
c'est que nous avions la preuve est pas
que le sentiment que notre art et
créativité avait assez mûri au point de
contribuer à la vie à la conception de
l'humanité est là le signal était donné
pour photo mais king version 3 et qu'est
ce qui se passe en photo mec
l'innovation 3 non ce n'est pas ici vous
en entendrez parler
photo mc une version 3
et la réunion de deux passions de paul
et qu'est ce qui va se passer
ce qui n'avait pas été achevés
ira maintenant vers sa conclusion
vers sa réalisation
le projet d'art collaboratif massif
sera déployée afin de cette fois ci
n'ont pas contribué seulement à la vie
d'une personne
mais de par sa nature contribuent à la
vie d'un milliard de personnes
et si et c'est ce qui va arriver
et pour vous donner un aperçu de ce qui
va arriver permettez moi
permettez moi de prendre 10 secondes de
votre temps et imaginez s'il vous plaît
avec moi imaginez s'il vous plaît
imaginez la possibilité d'interroger une
nation entière
et de recevoir ses réponses en une
fraction de seconde
sans intermédiaire
voici ce sur quoi nous sommes en train
de travailler le nom de code de ce
projet et chères amies et chers amis
je serai bien honoré
que cette belle audience de tedx ici
soit la première à recevoir cette oeuvre
là qu'elle sera accompli
et pourquoi parce que
l'évolution
ou la révolution peut naître dans le
dans l'esprit d'une personne mais c'est
bien la communauté qui l'amène à sa
réalisation
ainsi
avec les types cedex on a échangé on
s'est dit voici ce qu'on pourrait faire
on pourrait envoyer
dans les mois à venir un mail aux 1500
personnes qui sont qui participe
aujourd'hui à ce telex afin qu'ils
puissent
aller chercher cette oeuvre là qui
quelque part leur revient
parce que cet arbre collaboratif et
massif
l avenir de de tout un monde si nous y
prenons tous ensemble
merci